vous a pas échappé que depuis de
nombreux mois ce sont les fonctionnaires
qui sont en première ligne pour
accompagner le pays dans la crise
sanitaire qui a que nous subissons tous
et la plupart de ces fonctionnaires sont
plus souvent ceux qui sont les moins
bien rémunérés la fonction publique
j'entends par là qu'il y a peu de temps
à la ministre sont au regret de devoir
d'avoir ramené les les traitement
indiciaire des fonctionnaires en fait
qui fait là référence de leur salaire au
niveau du smic alors que depuis de
nombreux mois en fait un fonctionnaire
et est statutairement payer moins que le
smic ça a été un rattrapage ce n'est en
aucun cas une augmentation moi je vous
interrogerait simplement c'est que tous
les jours à l'heure où nous parlons ce
matin d'ici quelques minutes
tout le monde va reprendre son activité
professionnelle rejoindre par exemple
emmener son enfant à l'école
est ce que quelqu'un s'est jamais
interrogé quel était le le salaire de la
personne qui accueille sept enfants à
l'école
un axe fonctionne en catégorie c est
payé au smic à l'heure actuelle avec la
réévaluation qui a été fait par parité
un fonctionnaire de catégorie b en début
de carrière est payé à peine 40 euros au
dessus du smic
un fonctionnaire de catégorie à 1 14
blessés baca catégorie a c'est un peu
plus élevé est levée et pays
quelques centaines d'euros dessus ce ne
sont pas des nantis ses agents ont été
en première ligne tout le long de la
crise ils ont été les seuls contacts
parfois pour la plupart de la population
et pour autant ce sont parmi les plus
bas salaires de france pour la plupart
d'entre eux maintenant cette demande
d'un vrai rendez vous salarial et non
pas de dessous poudrage comme nous ça il
est plus question d'avoir de
revalorisation il faut être proactif
il faut rappeler que la fonction
publique a c'est une vraie valeur
ajoutée pour le pays
c'est un investissement cet
investissement nous a permis de tenir
pendant plus d'un an alors que si jamais
on avait dû reporter une partie des
services public sur le privé il est
évident qu'une partie de la population
et essai était laissée à l'abandon faute
de droite et gauche sur tout le
territoire
à force de détruire la fonction publique
d'en détruire l'image et d'oublier que
c'est une vraie valeur ajoutée pour le
pays on se rend compte que
les jeunes préfèrent partir vers le
privé on se rend compte également à
l'heure actuelle que dans la fonction
publique hospitalière
bon nombre d'agents démissionne et d'une
part faute de moyens pour pouvoir
exercer correctement leur métier
d'autre part parce que les salaires sont
moins en moins attractif avec la
pénibilité excellent traîne derrière et
bien les six agents partent travailler
dans le privé voit tout simplement
demain si on veut une fonction publique
qui nous permettent de maintenir la
qualité de service public est ce qui est
quand même le ciment en fait de notre
pays parce que c'est là on retrouve en
fait des soirs de maison commune nommée
rice et les maisons communes de nos de
nos collectivités
c'est l'endroit où l'essentiel des
services publics at-il demain on n'a
plus d'argent public pour pouvoir faire
à fonctionner ses services comment
va-t-on faire
on va tout déléguer au privé il est bien
évident que si demain on demande la même
réactivité et les mêmes exigences du nca
d'un service privé on n'aura pas la même
qualité
c'est pas que le lait les entreprises
privées ne sache pas faire c'est que
tout simplement un service public c'est
déjà une continuité de service c'est
déjà des agents qui sont sollicités
régulièrement dans des domaines qui
parfois dépassent parce qu'on a souvent
des agents qui sont de catégorie 6 à qui
on demande d'effectuer des missions de
catégorie b
mais parfois c'est juste parce que l'on
manque d'effectif pas ce qu'on leur
demande plus qu'ils ne sont normalement
payé et rémunéré pour faire le service
public c'est vraiment un engagement au
delà même d'un travail c'est un
engagement c'est pas l'effet de la prime
à vide qui a eu quelques effets sur les
amis nation parce que tous n'ont pas
perçu notamment les politiques
territoriales où ça relève d'une
délibération
c'est un régime indemnitaire libre
administration des collectivités
territoriales y'a pas une obligation de
verser ce qui est une vraie
reconnaissance pour les agents c'est un
salaire décent et qui leur permettent de
survivre
on ne peut plus continuer à voir arriver
un traitement indiciaire pour un agent
public qui soit en dessous du smic haute
certes l'état n'est pas en capacité de
suivre l'évolution du pouvoir d'achat de
l'inflation et c'est comme les comme le
fait autrement
les entreprises privées mais à ce moment
là il faut avoir le salaire de base